[Aplausos]
piensen en una ecuación una fórmula la
que primera ustedes ven a la cabeza la
tiene
casi con total seguridad muchos habrán
pensado en esta
mi nombre es manuel fernández y hoy
vamos a buscar la energía infinita con
esta ecuación probablemente la más
famosa de la historia de la física
einstein nos enseñó nos demostró que la
materia y la energía son en realidad la
misma cosa
la energía permea absolutamente todo en
el universo y todos los seres vivos
todos utilizamos la energía de uno u
otro modo sin embargo lo que distingue a
los seres humanos lo que nos hace
especiales es nuestra habilidad y
nuestra capacidad para manipular y
controlar fuentes externas de energía
externas a nosotros mismos porque la
historia de la humanidad es la historia
de la conquista de fuentes externas de
energía si uno piensa en los primeros
homínidos únicamente eran capaces de
utilizar la débil fuerza de sus músculos
tardaron millones millones de años en
domesticar los animales pudiendo
entonces externalizar por ejemplo una
forma más rápida de transportar se
tardaron miles de años más en darse
cuenta que podían utilizar la fuerza del
viento para mover barcos o la fuerza del
viento y del agua para mover molinos que
podían moler grano por ejemplo
siempre que ha habido a lo largo de la
historia algún tipo de evolución en
materia de energía las condiciones de
vida del ser humano mejoraron y de hecho
en los momentos de la historia donde
apenas hubo ninguna evolución energética
las condiciones del ser humano
permanecieron estables en la miseria
porque la historia de ser humanos en la
historia desgraciadamente de miseria
así fueron pasando los siglos porque en
el antiguo egipto la esperanza de vida
era de apenas 25 años la grecia clásica
y en la antigua roma la esperanza de
vida era de 30 años los siglos pasaron y
pasaron sin que nada mejorará en las
condiciones de vida del ser humano de
hecho en la inglaterra del siglo 17 la
esperanza de vida seguía siendo de 30
años como en la antigua roma y entonces
algo pasó algo pasó en la europa del
siglo 18 el uso de una nueva fuente de
energía el carbón unido a la invención
de la máquina de vapor sentaron las
bases de la revolución industrial pero
esta vez era diferente no era como las
demás
esta vez el ser humano había aprendido a
transformar la energía no sólo a usarla
había conseguido transformar el calor de
quemar carbón en movimiento
que movía máquinas esto fue una
auténtica revolución y se tradujo en una
serie de desarrollos tecnológicos que
condujeron al descubrimiento de la
electricidad la electricidad era una
nueva forma de energía que tenía una
peculiaridad absolutamente maravillosa
que se podía transportar se podía
producir en un sitio pero consumirse a
cientos de kilómetros de distancia
porque la energía que consumimos el tipo
de energía y la cantidad de energía es
lo que determina nuestra calidad de vida
porque consumir energía significa que
estamos externalizando la energía y
estamos haciendo que las máquinas
trabajen por nosotros y si una máquina
trabaja por mí no tengo que trabajar
acción
y eso es lo que hace que nosotros hoy
tengamos unos estándares de vida y una
calidad de vida y de imaginable siquiera
para la gente más rica de hace apenas 30
o 40 años
pero estos estándares de vida tienen un
peaje y el precio a pagar son grandes
consumos de energía el consumo de
cantidades ingentes de energía porque el
camino del progreso no se puede recorrer
sin consumir energía los países ricos
no consumimos energía porque somos ricos
sino que somos ricos precisamente porque
consumimos y hemos consumido grandes
cantidades de energía
y así consumiendo energía es como el ser
humano sale de la miseria y la esperanza
de vida en el mundo hoy es de 70 años en
europa supera los 80 años la tasa de
mortalidad infantil ha disminuido
drásticamente en las últimas décadas y
la tasa de pobreza de pobreza extrema en
el mundo ha caído drásticamente en los
últimos años probablemente nosotros
tengamos el honor de ser la primera
generación en la historia de la
humanidad en ver erradicada la pobreza
extrema del mundo
sin embargo no todos son buenas noticias
no podemos perder de vista que en el
mundo hoy casi 1000 millones de personas
no tienen acceso a electricidad
y 2500 millones de personas siguen
utilizando en el interior de sus casas
para cocinar y para calentarse la
combustión de madera residuos o
excrementos de animales respirar ese
humo produce al año 4 millones de
muertes prematuras esos son más muertes
que el sida la tuberculosis la malaria
la diabetes y los accidentes de tráfico
juntos
estas personas quieren y merecen una
vida mejor y van a luchar por tener una
vida mejor y una vida mejor implica el
consumo de cantidades ingentes de
energía si no ponemos una alternativa
encima de la mesa lo van a hacer se van
a desarrollar usando combustibles
fósiles afortunadamente tenemos
alternativas hace apenas unas décadas
que es nada en la historia de la
humanidad el ser humano aprende a
controlar y dominar una nueva fuente de
energía
una fuente millones de veces más intensa
que cualquiera de las energías conocidas
hasta entonces esto es como una pastilla
de óxido de uranio
este es el combustible que se utiliza en
los reactores nucleares que tenemos en
un reactor nuclear hay 15 millones de
pastillas como está bien en su tamaño
ínfimo a pesar de su pequeño tamaño esta
pastilla es capaz de producir la
electricidad que consume cada uno de
nosotros en cuatro años
con 20 pastillas como esta podemos
producir la electricidad que consumimos
cada uno de nosotros en toda nuestra
vida
si quisiéramos hacer lo mismo con carbón
necesitaríamos 16.000 kilos de carbón
16.000 kilos de carbón frente a 20
pastillas como ésta y además produce
electricidad las 24 horas del día los 7
días de la semana independientemente de
factores climatológicos y sin emitir
gases de efecto invernadero
por eso la energía nuclear es
imprescindible para afrontar el reto al
que se enfrenta la humanidad que es
descarbonizar las economías seguir
creando desarrollo y seguir sacando a
gente de la pobreza extrema de la
miseria sin emitir gases de efecto
invernadero
este es el consumo de energía en el
mundo hoy por mucho que nos pese y por
mucho que en los medios de comunicación
en el debate veamos otra cosa el mundo
sigue siendo fósil casi el 90% de la
energía del mundo sale de quemar
combustibles fósiles a pesar de los
ingentes esfuerzos que hemos hecho los
países ricos del mundo por desplegar
energías renovables su contribución a la
energía en el mundo sigue siendo mínima
por supuesto debemos seguir perseverando
en el camino las energías renovables
pero no podemos cerrar los ojos a la
realidad
la realidad no se hace porque cerremos
los ojos y lo deseemos muy fuerte la
realidad es como es
estos son hechos no palabras la energía
nuclear sigue produciendo más
electricidad que las energías renovables
y un mundo 100% renovable
desgraciadamente está todavía muy lejos
con todas las energías renovables del
mundo juntas no somos capaces ni
siquiera de producir la mitad de la
electricidad de eeuu
si cerramos nuestras centrales nucleares
si prescindimos de la energía nuclear
hoy
sería como no haber hecho nada entonces
estos años serían como volver de nuevo
al punto de partida
y haber tirado por la borda todo lo que
hemos luchado estos años a pesar de todo
esto la energía nuclear tiene un rechazo
social incontestable
sin duda porque no hemos sabido
transmitir lo que la energía nuclear
puede hacer por la humanidad pero
podemos hacer reactores nucleares que
sean más eficientes podemos hacer
reactores nucleares que utilicen mejor
los recursos naturales que tenemos
podemos hacer reactores nucleares que
produzcan menos residuos radiactivos es
más somos capaces de hacer reactores
nucleares que puedan utilizar como
combustible los residuos radioactivos
que ya tenemos reciclando los la
respuesta está en el interior del núcleo
de un átomo que se llama torio
victorio es un elemento que se encuentra
la naturaleza en una abundancia cuatro
veces mayor a la del uranio y recibe su
nombre del dios nórdico del trueno thor
como vemos en este dibujo que ha hecho
especialmente para esta conferencia mi
diseñadora favorita
existen varios diseños de reactores en
el mundo que pueden utilizar el torio
como combustible nuclear pero hay uno de
ellos en especial que tiene unas
características que lo hacen inigualable
la primera de ellas es que el
combustible que utiliza es líquido está
fundida esto hace que los reactores de
torio sean más seguros porque no pueden
tener lugar accidentes en los cuales el
núcleo se funda como por ejemplo pasó en
fukushima porque el núcleo ya está
fundido por diseño estos reactores
operan a una altísima temperatura 700
grados además de ser mucho más
eficientes para la producción de
electricidad esa enorme fuente de calor
sirve para una multitud de usos
industriales por ejemplo la producción
masiva de hidrógeno que podría
solucionar el problema del transporte a
nivel mundial o podríamos utilizar
técnicas de secuestro y captura de co2
de la atmósfera sacar carbono donde
llevamos tirando los cientos de años y
con este hidrógeno utilizarlo para
construir para fabricar hidrocarburos
sintéticos estaríamos hablando de
gasolina neutra en carbono de gasolinas
estos reactores además tienen seguridad
pasiva lo que implica que no necesito
múltiples sistemas de seguridad
redundantes y puedo construir reactores
mucho más compactos y mucho más pequeños
porque más pequeño significa mucho más
barato además estos reactores pueden
producirse en serie en cadenas de
producción disminuyendo además sus
costes de fabricación pero sin duda una
de las ventajas claras de estos
reactores es que los residuos
radioactivos que producen tienen una
vida media de apenas 300 años en
comparación con las decenas o centenas
de miles de años de los residuos
radiactivos que tenemos ahora y esto es
así porque estos reactores no producen
plutonio ni ningún otro elemento
superior de la tabla periódica de larga
vida media el hecho de que no produzcan
plutonio ya es una enorme ventaja por sí
mismo porque estos reactores no sirven
para fabricar bombas nucleares
y además por si fuera poco estos
reactores son capaces de utilizar los
residuos radioactivos de larga vida que
ya tenemos como combustible reciclando
los y haciendo que desaparezcan
convirtiendo la energía nuclear en una
energía sostenible
pero la mejor de las ventajas de estos
reactores es la eficiencia en el uso de
los recursos naturales los reactores
nucleares que tenemos en la actualidad
únicamente son capaces de extraer el 1
por ciento de la energía de la pastilla
de uranio que les mostré el otro 99% la
energía contenida en la pastilla no
somos capaces de utilizarla sin embargo
estos reactores son capaces de usar casi
el 100% de la energía contenida en el
torio una esfera de torio de este tamaño
de este volumen sería suficiente para
abastecer la energía que consumimos cada
uno de nosotros en toda nuestra vida con
energía no me refiero sobre la
electricidad me refiero a la
electricidad la calefacción el
transporte y todo
además que se les ocurra con nueve mil
toneladas de torio al año que se pueden
sacar de una única mina del tamaño de un
campo de fútbol seríamos capaces de
abastecer la demanda energética de todo
el planeta
si quisiéramos hacer lo mismo por
ejemplo quemando madera necesitaríamos
talar el amazonas' entero cada año
esto significa que con las reservas de
torio que tenemos ahora mismo en la
tierra las reservas conocidas somos
capaces de abastecer la demanda de
energía de toda la humanidad
durante miles de
estos reactores no son una utopía no son
un diseño en un papel no son ciencia
ficción estos reactores ya los diseñamos
los construimos y los hicimos funcionar
en la década de los años 60 son una
tecnología probada son una tecnología
que funciona sin embargo los años 60
después de la segunda guerra mundial los
objetivos y las prioridades eran otros
unos reactores nucleares que no
producían plutonio y no servían para
producir bombas atómicas no tenían
interés alguno y su desarrollo se
abandonó simplemente debemos retomarlo y
seguir
invirtiendo en este tipo de reactores
afortunadamente sus bajos costes de
producción de operación y de
mantenimiento hacen que esto sea una
realidad y ya hay diversas empresas en
el mundo empujando este tipo de diseños
es el ser humano es la acción humana la
que transforma recursos naturales
inservibles que no tenían ninguna
utilidad en piedras angulares del
desarrollo y del progreso el carbón el
petróleo el gas natural el uranio e
incluso el torio siempre han estado ahí
han estado en la tierra millones de años
nunca han tenido ningún uso nunca han
servido para nada hasta que el ser
humano les ha dado un uso
al igual que el hombre de las cavernas
no fue capaz de predecir cuáles serían
las enormes implicaciones para la
calidad de vida que tendría el
descubrimiento del fuego el hombre del
siglo 18 tampoco fue capaz de predecir
cuáles serían las maravillosas
consecuencias de la revolución
industrial para la calidad de vida de
los hombres
del mismo modo aquí estamos hoy con una
nueva fuente de energía en la palma de
la mano capaz de abastecer la demanda
energética de la humanidad durante miles
de años de manera estable segura limpia
y barata usarla o no usarla depende de
nosotros las ventajas de hacerlo serían
inimaginables y las consecuencias de no
hacerlo serían impersonales muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]